i want to read the story to you guys and
it's going to be part of this
conversation i want to get your feedback
so new york times
children have fallen way behind in
reading
and that could put their futures at risk
last spring as it was becoming clear
that the pandemic learning
loss was real and a serious problem for
some kids there were some voices
suggesting the best approach to the
problem was to not test for it okay
brilliant idea right and some educations
professionals went further and claimed
that standardized tests weren't really
measuring all the good things
kids kept out of school were learning
the president-elect teachers union
outright said there is no such thing as
learning the law she continued it's okay
that our babies may not have learned all
their times uh tables they learned
resilience they learned survival they
learned critical thinking skills they
know the difference between a riot and a
protest they know the words insurrection
and coup oh my god that's just that's oh
my goodness now the new york times
reports that in virginia one case study
found that
uh early reading skills were at a
20-year low
this fall which researchers described as
alarming in the boston region 60 of
students at some high poverty schools
have been identified as at high risk for
reading problems twice the number of
students
as before the pandemic thoughts
so
my husband took my 13 month old daughter
to our local library because who doesn't
love that and this was like a week or
two ago and he walks in the library
walks over to the children's section she
because she likes to read books already
she's actually like that since she was
like eight or nine months
and
as soon as they got to the children's
section the children's librarian came
over to them and said sir you have to
wear a mask
and he said oh what do you mean to who
you're my husband yeah okay and my
husband's like oh why there's nobody in
here
and i'm not sick and the librarian was
just like oh that's our policy now we
live in a state where it's been lifted
there's no mass mandate there's a public
library we fund it my husband was like
oh why is it your policy and the
librarian was like do you want to talk
to the library manager
and my husband's like yes i do
so he the library manager comes down
and says oh sir it's our policy that you
have to wear a mask my husband goes may
i ask why
and he said well because that's what the
cdc says that's the cdc guidance and my
husband's like sure but i'm not sick
i've already had covid twice i have
natural immunity you're not sick even
the cdc says cloth cloth masks aren't
effective anymore so why and the only
thing that this library manager could
say was well that's what the cdc says
that's what the cdc says and so we're
talking about this afterward and we're
we're it's just i mean first of all it's
really annoying right it's very annoying
but it's also just so fundamentally
telling
about this lack of critical thinking and
the lack of critical thinking people
don't think for themselves they don't
acknowledge that oh because the cdc is
supposedly higher on the hierarchy than
we are we the sorry people are that they
could be wrong that they shouldn't just
be obeyed that they that you could it's
okay to be skeptical and i mean this
this ties into teaching teaching
children
to critically think and not just to echo
certain beliefs that's not what liberals
think anymore they don't want children
to they don't care about children
learning the times tables because what
is mathematics unless you're going to be
an engineer it's a way of disciplining
your mind to learn how to you know put
variables together and draw a conclusion
that's it's how to it's logic right they
don't want children to learn that
because as soon as you learn logic as
soon as you learn how to think for
yourself then you start questioning
their authority so i know this sounds
like a deep
a deep dark conspiracy to take over the
minds of our children but i think
parents across the country this isn't
just republicans or conservatives this
is democrats and liberals who are seeing
the disservice that's being done to our
children and understanding that listen
if we want to if we want our country to
be what it is we have to take this back
this is not what we want for our kids
tom what do you think about this that's
apparent how do you process this well
there's two sides here the educational
side and then the home side the
enablement side and the on the
enablement side we become a video based
society look at the internet the
internet is very video based and the
amount of depth of articles it's hard to
find them medium has them slate has them
and conservative places have them but
that's not where the traffic is the
traffic is for video and short burst and
so they're a short attention span
theater going on throughout the lives so
it's hard to get a child to
take the time and sit and read i mean
you see it as a parent pat it's getting
increasingly difficult to get your kid
to sit for 45 minutes 30 minutes 45
minutes and actually focus and read so
the first problem is the video based
society and not reinforcing the value of
reading and doing it for parents that
have the resources to do so the other
side of it is that
the schools and the types of books and
resources are available in the
disciplines that they're putting in in
the children to do that because they're
not emphasizing on reading the test
scores are dropping for not for any
other reason in that the
number of minutes that they spend
reading is dropping that's why the test
scores are dropping so now the tests are
bad so there's two sides the problem is
how they're educating intentionally
and then the other side is parents have
to be active participants in this and
turn off video based
you know massaging of their brain and
get them to read because reading builds
reasoning not the other way around when
you read your mind is focused to reason
with what's happening with the character
because you're not being told you're
interpreting and when you're just told
turn left turn left turn left you turn
left
so there's a couple sides to this
you know
from the la teachers union she says
outright there's no such thing as
learning loss i think she's absolutely
incorrect on that if you're not reading
and you're not studying and you're not
focusing on school
yeah you're going to forget some stuff
you're not going to improve on stuff and
across the united states you can see the
public schools there's how many schools
are just failing or not getting good
grades but i will say she does have a
point on one thing that
you know there's a we talked about this
yesterday at lunch there is a difference
between iq and eq book smarts and street
smarts so you know again this comes down
to parenting and what you're doing with
your kids at home are you like for
instance i don't care what you're the
schools are doing you're making your
kids read
but if they're spending more just like
you're doing with with your kids i'm
sure yeah i mean you have a
13 year old that is already reading you
know
uh
major books apparently is but yeah by
herself she reads them yeah exactly so
but i you know there there there is
something to be said that during a
pandemic like this when there's a lot of
different stuff going on
and a lot of the world is changing so
fast you know having conversations with
your kids like hey this is what's going
on critical thinking like you talked
about there's see there needs to be a
lot more critical thinking with your
kids at home why are you home right now
are you going to hang out with your
friends is it worth hanging out with
your friends i don't know you're going
to get sick hang with your friends are
you is it worth going to school what do
you think about zoom
street smarts is is a real thing you
know i you know you you know quite
candidly talk about how you had a 1.8
gpa
but you were very popular in school you
were good at sports you were very high
on street smarts and maps yeah but
there's a difference here though i was
around people
i was around people i was not uh uh
alienated and you know parents still
have to work and it was a very weird 18
months for the average parent forget
about the the people that have money
they figured out a way to get a nanny or
two but the parents schools were still
in school it was a mess so you have to
know that for them to use that as an
excuse to say our kids learned about
what was the thing we learned about that
learning about
interactions is is sort of absurd
testing and riots
rather than uh
teaching some things so no i i
understand what you're saying i
understand what you're saying with the
point she's making that hey there's more
things to iq than you got to get good at
eq all this other stuff no
i want you to learn logically to make
better decisions that's what i want you
to learn okay as a kid
my my dad taught me how to think that
was his thing it was teaching me how to
think you know one of the things we
talked about i made a video a few years
ago saying 15 things they don't teach
you at school if i ever ran a school
the next 20 years we're doing media the
last 20 years if we ever decide to start
a university or a high school if we ever
did and it was a private school we would
be teaching certain things that these
guys don't want to teach we would teach
you how taxes work
the specific tax code and why
entrepreneurs pay
taxes because of the sacrifices they
take and versus deciding to be an
entrepreneur there's different dynamics
we teach you how to sell we teach you
how to lead we teach you how money works
we teach you how to negotiate we teach
you how to think for yourself we teach
you how to start a business we teach how
to earn millions how to process issues
how to marry no one's teaching you how
to marry what is this marriage thing all
about you get married all of a sudden
like holy moly i don't have a manual for
this
how many marriage books do i need to
read by people that have been divorced
seven times what do i need to learn to
how mary so i want to sit i want to have
a panel of a husband and wife that i've
been married for 40 years i want a panel
of a person that's been divorced three
times i want a panel of a person that's
newlywed and i want them to debate
somebody that doesn't believe in
marriage in a single 55 years old why
let the kids say i kind of lean towards
this guy i don't want to get married i
kind of lean towards this side i'm
afraid this guy got a divorce but i
learned we're not doing these things so
for them to say
we learned the difference between a coup
and an insurrection
who gave a [ __ ] about that at 10 years
old 11 12 years old what are we talking
about so is that what we're feeding into
their minds being the most important the
classes you're talking about goes to my
point is that those are street smart
type things those are emotional
intelligence things yeah marriage
entrepreneurship how to make money
that's not iq you can't do anything
algebra but you give this [ __ ] about you
can't do no but algebra but math is very
much about processing trigonometry
i think math analysis is about
processing issues it is because it is
all the way through calculus i fully
agree i think you know the whole thing
about einstein would say the difference
between uh somebody wins and somebody
doesn't like
uh prefacing what he said it was the
successful people stay with problems
longer right math is about i can't
figure this freaking thing out how the
hell does this work you stay with the
problem longer you solve it then for the
rest of your life you're having a
problem in a business and a relationship
and a friendship you stay with the
problem longer you figure it out rather
than saying i'm just not working out
boom here's what i'm doing i think math
is all that anyways we learn by being
around each other we learn by being
around each other we learn by this
discourse right the kids lost that 18
months most middle low-income people in
california new york they lost it scores
in boston 60 it's pathetic so if you
enjoyed this little segment from the
podcast click over here to watch the
entire podcast and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
take care everybody
[Music]